today on the matt wall show joe biden
picks a black supremacist to lead the
doj civil rights division we'll see what
could possibly go wrong with that also
five headlines including
andrew cuomo's lockdown 180 plus another
democrat impeachment pageant and camilla
harris
is being persecuted because of a
magazine cover where she's wearing
casual shoes
that and much more today on the matte
wall show
[Music]
[Applause]
well i want to take a second here to
tell you about our friends at legacy box
you know legacy box is a really easy
effortless way to
digitally preserve your home movies and
photos so that you never have to wonder
where they are or or whether they're
safe you don't have to worry about them
getting ruined or anything like that
and you shouldn't wait this is the kind
of thing you shouldn't wait to do
because if you've got all these memories
stored in a box somewhere in the the
basement or the attic
you don't know what could happen to them
and where you could lose them they could
be destroyed anything could happen
and that's why you want to get them
digitized and you want to do it now i've
done it myself
uh and you know i can tell you that the
experience with legacy box
is really really easy on your end i
wouldn't know if i wanted to take all
these
home movies and photographs i want to
digitize all them i wouldn't know how to
do it
so instead i just put it in a box i
mailed to legacy box and then they mail
it back to me and it's really that
simple with legacy box you can have all
that footage organized and preserved
quickly and easily
the service is shockingly simple you use
their kit to safely send the moments
that you want preserved
their experience team will create a
digital collection by hand and then it
all come back to you stored it on
on the cloud a thumb drive or dvd along
with the original media that you sent we
got it
back on a thumb drive and it was really
just i can't stress enough just how
easy it is to do uh even if you wanted
to do this yourself it would cost
hundreds of dollars to do
and why do that because when you visit
legacybox.com today you'll save 50
off you can get started for a little as
little as 39 bucks
so go to legacybox.com walsh take
advantage of this limited time offer and
get 50
off this exclusive offer won't last long
so order their kit now and send it in
whenever you're ready go to legacy box
dot com slash walsh and save 50
while supplies last so yesterday we
played the clip of joe biden unveiling
his plan to help struggling business
owners
in the wake of the lockdowns that have
crippled them
in a sign of things to come biden says
that his administration's priority will
be black latino native american
and women business owners in other words
white males are out of luck so let's
play that again in case you missed it
here it is
our focus will be on small businesses on
main street
that aren't wealthy and well connected
that are facing real economic hardships
through no
fault of their own our priority will be
black latino asian and native
american-owned small businesses
women-owned businesses
and finally having equal access to
resources needed to reopen and rebuild
now as always with these things if you
want to understand just how outrageously
racist it is just play it back in your
mind but insert white male
instead of black or latino imagine if
joe biden had said
our priority will be white males and
white women
there would be a volcanic eruption of
outrage in response to such a statement
nearly every person in the country
would condemn it as the height of racism
so
is it different if you fill in the blank
with a different race no of course not
the reaction is different what people
say about it is different but
it's not actually different um
imagine also actually being a white male
business owner some of you may not have
to imagine this because you are
you're on the brink of bankruptcy in
desperate need of some help
due to the government's own actions and
now imagine that you you don't get the
help you need
because of your race and gender are you
supposed to be okay with that are you
supposed to
look down at your white skin and say
well all right i guess i
do deserve to lose my livelihood at
least the latinos are getting help
i suppose that's how biden expects them
to react or perhaps not biden it's not
clear that biden expects anything
it's not clear that he knows what
centuries in or planet he's on but the
radicals calling the shots
for him do expect it speaking of
radicals tucker carlson had a disturbing
segment last night about kristen
clarke clark has been tapped to lead the
doj civil rights division
this means that she'll be a very
powerful figure in the administration
and given that she's in charge of
enforcing quote-unquote civil rights
it's important to know how she views the
subject right
well tucker had obtained a letter that
clarke wrote back in 1994
when she was the president of the black
studies association
at harvard clark was looking to educate
the public on the topic of
race science and if race science
sounds like horrible quackery if it
sounds like something you
might learn at medical school in nazi
germany that's because it is
so here's tucker reading the letter
listen please use the following
theories and observations to assist you
in your search for truth regarding the
genetic differences between blacks and
whites
and quotes you know it's going to be
interesting and it was quote
one dr richard king reveals that the
core of the human brain
is the locus corulius which is a
structure that is black
because it contains large amounts of
neuromelanin which is essential for its
operation
two black infants sit crawl and walk
sooner than whites three carol barnes
notes that human mental processes are
controlled
by melanin that same chemical which
gives blacks their superior physical and
mental
abilities four some scientists have
revealed that most
whites are unable to produce melanin
because their pineal glands are often
calcified
or non-functioning pineal calcification
rates with africans are five to fifteen
percent
asians fifteen to twenty five percent
and europeans sixty to eighty percent
this is the chemical basis for the
cultural differences between blacks and
whites
and five melanin endows blacks with
greater mental
physical and spiritual abilities
something which cannot be measured based
on eurocentric standards
end quote oh okay
that's science for you now if this
sounds familiar and i heard this
and uh and i the first thing i thought
is i feel like i've heard this
recently well if you had the same
thought you might be thinking of this
listen let's go to what it really is
then when we talk about the power of
melanated people
when we talk about who we really are as
guys and understanding that
our melanin is so power and it connects
us in a way
that the reason why they fear black the
reason why they fear is because they
the lack that they have of it so then
when you see
what you know dr uh francis c wellesley
talked about
is that fear in that that that genetic
annihilation efficiency
of when you have a person that has has
the lack of pigment the lack of melon
right that they know that they will be
annihilated
so therefore however they got the power
they
they they have the lack of compassion
that
melanin comes with compassion melanin
comes with soul that we call it we call
it soul we soul brothers and sisters
that's the melon in that connection so
the people that don't have it
have are are a lit and i'm gonna say
this carefully
are a little less you said it carefully
they're a little less the entire race of
people a little bit less i always like
in you know we watch clips like that and
uh when someone is babbling incoherently
and somebody else is listening and going
right yeah sure
uh-huh exactly the entire time so anyway
yes the doj civil rights division will
be run by nick cannon
essentially or at least someone as
racist and insane
and stupid as him so a few things to be
said
about all this number one it should go
without saying but the science here
is not only wrong but incoherent it's
not really science at all but religious
dogma a belief that darker skin endows
one not only with mental and physical
advantages but with greater spiritual
and moral worth
you know white people are a little less
as the scholar nick cannon put it that's
not science at all obviously number two
this sort of race essentialism makes for
really strange bedfellows with gender
non-essentialism which is increasingly
the world view of everybody on the left
both in the mainstream and off on the
fringes
and the distinction between those two
groups leftist mainstream and leftist
fringe has of course been almost
completely erased at this point
a mainstream leftist is just a fringe
leftist but without the blue hair
in any case the race essentialist said
that says that races are biologically
distinct
that every race has its own core essence
that's what you heard nick cannon and
kristen clark talking about and that
your race is immutable it's an
unchangeable part of you but
gender non-essentialism on the other
hand says that sex has
nothing to do with biology that there is
no core essence to being a man or a
woman
that's why they can't answer my famous
question of what is a woman well a woman
is nothing
although they don't want to say that and
they say you know you can switch between
the two
sexes or you can be neither or you could
be some combination you know you could
be a man on tuesday and a woman on
wednesday there's no reason why you
can't be
in other words they seek to make nearly
everything about you nearly your whole
identity fluid and ambiguous
except your race we are all basically
these amorphous
genderless non-descript puddles of
nothing
but we do have a race at least and god
forbid that an ambiguous
white entity should pretend to be an
ambiguous black entity never mind that
it makes just as much sense for a white
man to say
i feel like a black person and so i am
one as it does for a man to say
i feel like i'm a woman and so i am one
these statements are
at least equal in their incoherence if
anything the former is slightly less
incoherent
number three notice how the cycle has
been complete now the leftist
champions for racial equality to include
now even the the woman who will be
heading up the civil rights division
sound exactly like the proponents of jim
crow in the early 20th century
some races have greater spiritual and
moral worth that's exactly what racists
have
always said and it's what people like
kristen clarke have pretended
that they're fighting against but in an
outcome that is
familiar in human history they have
become exactly what
they said they wanted to destroy they
are so woke
so enlightened so progressive that their
views on race would would have been
totally at home
in alabama in the year 1922. the only
difference is which race
they find superior but that is a rather
meaningless
difference really the end goal with all
of this
is to divide and conquer right for all
the talk about unity what we will see in
the coming years is the american
population divided
chopped up segregated into their own
categories
and policies will be applied and laws
enforced differently depending on the
category in which you reside
we are about to see the culmination of
identity politics we're going to see
what it looks like
when the sorts of people who've been
burning our cities for months now have a
whole government at their disposal
and old joe will preside over this half
conscious
barely sentient a useful stooge and
figurehead
an inoffensive and sort of pitiful
vessel for the most extreme radicalism
we have ever seen from our government
that's what's coming up but now let's
get to our five headlines
[Music]
four or five headlines today you know we
tell we've told you many times about
uh our loyal sponsors at rock auto and
the reason for that is because
it's it's just a it's a great company a
great service
uh and you can't beat it if you're
looking for auto parts it's so
there's there's just no reason to go to
the auto parts store when you can go to
rockauto.com
so much easier than walking in dealing
with all the questions
uh finding that they don't have what you
need in in stock
instead you go to rockauto.com where
you're gonna get the lowest prices
possible
they're not gonna change the prices
based on you know what the market
will bear anything like that they're
gonna they're gonna give you the lowest
possible price and so you know that so
you have that that peace of mind that
confidence
when you're looking at it at rock auto
you don't have to think well could i
find this cheaper somewhere else
because you know well you found it on
rock auto so it's it's as cheap as it's
going to get
rockauto.com is a family business
they've been serving auto parts
customers online
for 20 years go to rockauto.com to shop
for auto and body parts from hundreds of
manufacturers
the rockauto.com catalog is unique uh
very easy to navigate you can quickly
see all the parts
that may be available for your vehicle
and you can choose the brands the
specifications the the prices that you
prefer
it's really that simple go to
rockauto.com
right now see all the parts available
for your car truck right walsh in there
how did you hear about his box
so that they know that we sent you well
you know the good news though is that uh
warner brothers has submitted uh wonder
woman 1984 for consideration for 15
academy awards including best pictures
so
we'll see how that works out uh
apparently i've never watched either
wonder woman movie apparently everyone
hated this latest wonder woman movie i
guess it's it's
they don't like it uh but they like the
first one
i i don't know it's just for me
you shouldn't be surprised when a movie
called wonder woman isn't good
it's it's a it's a right it's she she
flies in an invisible jet
and she has a magic lasso am i getting
this right
and her name is wonder woman and you
expected it to not be horrible
is that what you expected and
you know of course the the unspoken
truth here that that nobody wants to say
is that really all female superhero
movies are terrible i mean they all
really are
uh no no i'm not saying they have to be
i'm not saying it's impossible to make a
female superhero movie
that's good it's just they haven't done
it yet and part of the problem is that
so often you know it's it's they're so
they want us to be so impressed with the
fact that it is a female superhero and
so that's
they're just driving that message home
the girl power thing
no just make an interesting superhero
movie and the superhero
happens to be a woman that's the way it
should be
you don't need to beat us over the head
with the girl power stuff every second
that's what they do
and um that's why the movie is isn't it
in case you're wondering why wonder
woman isn't good it's because again it's
it's a wonder woman what were you
expecting all right number one um
governor cuomo is singing a different
tune a radically
different tune um all of a sudden
although
maybe not maybe we can't call it a
coincidental because as we get closer to
the biden administration
now governor cuomo is uh sounding very
different here's what he said yesterday
about the lockdowns listen we simply
cannot stay
closed until the vaccine hits critical
mass
the cost is too high we will have
nothing
left to open we must reopen the economy
but we must do it smartly and safely
also we must energize our lagging
private sector and rebuild our economic
platform our transportation system our
infrastructure system
for the next generation of growth
i mean this is really i want to call it
amazing i know i shouldn't
because i shouldn't be surprised but
now he says that after
months and months and months of this and
you've got thousands of business owners
in that state alone
completely destroyed and now he's saying
well we can't just stay closed until
there's a vaccine
oh really yes that's what a lot of us
have been saying for months
and up until just 15 seconds ago
and andrew cuomo would have said to the
people who were saying what he just said
oh they're science deniers or they don't
care they don't care about grandma
i think we're gonna see a lot of uh
we're gonna see a lot of that we're
gonna see a lot of very sudden changes
in the in the coming weeks with respect
to
lockdowns and part of the reason is that
you know democrat governor
want a democrat president to be
presiding over
economic collapse
when really you would hope that they
just wouldn't want an economic collapse
at all but
that's not the way they look at these
things okay number two
um donald trump just very recently spoke
to the media i believe this is the first
time he's
spoken to the media and he spoke briefly
but the first time since everything
happened on wednesday
and uh here is some of what he had to
say
i think that big tech is doing
a horrible thing for our country and to
our country
and i believe it's going to be a
catastrophic mistake for them
they're dividing and divisive
and they're showing something that i've
been predicting for a long time
i've been predicting it for a long time
and people didn't act on it
but i think big tech has made a terrible
mistake and very very bad for our
country
and that's leading others to do the same
thing
and it causes a lot of problems and a
lot of danger
big mistake they shouldn't be doing it
but
there's always a counter move when they
do that i've never seen such anger
as i see right now and that's a terrible
thing
uh i'm i'm sorry but i just have no
patience for this whatsoever
trump says i've been predicting they'll
do this for a long
uh i knew it was going to happen well
okay then why don't you do anything
about it
why don't you worry the republicans do a
damn thing about it
do you predict thanks for predicting it
nice job nostradamus but what did did
you do anything
the republicans
controlled the entire government for two
years didn't do a damn thing
and that's the honest truth of the
matter didn't do a damn thing
i'm sorry they passed tax cuts
so they did do that so we got some tax
cuts
what else did they do i'm thinking back
to it now
they control the government for two
years what else do they do they pass
they pass them taxes oh and they they
confirm judges that's what i always hear
well they confirmed judges of course
they did that
the vacancies were open they filled them
but that's like bear
that's the barest of bare minimums
obviously you're gonna do that what are
they gonna do not fill the vacancies
you know we don't give republicans
credit for just filling a vacancy when
it's there
that takes zero effort of
of the things that would have taken some
kind of effort the things they actually
had to
fight for and do
what if that was actually done now
to reign in big tech that would have
been a difficult
major undertaking they didn't even
try the thing with republicans is they
try to do things
when they know it can't be done anymore
so they wait until they're out of power
and then they start saying we need to do
this and that
because they know they can't do it so
there's no pressure
it's the same thing they did with
defunding planned parenthood up until
the moment when they actually controlled
the government
up until that moment so many republicans
were saying we got to defund planned
parenthood it's got to be defunded
i would go to the rallies and you know
some of these lawmakers would show up
and they would give
great speeches about how we need to
defund planned parenthood
videos came out a few years ago showing
that planned parenthood is selling baby
parts
it's kind of a big deal a lot of
republicans said we got to defend it
it's just at the time they didn't have
the the power to do it so they said
you know geez i'd love to defund it but
uh we just don't have the power
i'd love to i really wish we could darn
it
and then what did we say we said okay
we'll give you the power here it is
here's all the power
and they said planned parenthood what's
that i never heard of it what are you
talking about
now we'll get to that in a second i got
we got these tax cuts we got to pass
didn't even try becomes a defining plan
parenthood didn't even try
and so now trump says uh we got a well
for every move there's a counter move
really what's your counter move
you're out of office in a week and a
half you have no power right now
that's what we're waiting for the
counter move i'm just
i'm i'm tired of this too from
conservatives it's you know it's sitting
trust the plan and i mean some of that
is the wacky q
stuff about did they say trust the plan
but but there's there's an attitude of
that
even outside of queue or conservatives
say oh i'm sure it's all gonna work out
there's there's a plan behind the scenes
and
yeah they've got it trust us they're
gonna do it
nope no plan trump's gonna be out of
office in a week and a half
uh republicans will be in the minority
and there was no plan nothing was
happening
the plan all along was to do nothing and
just buy their time that was the plan
but i'm glad that trump predicted it
anyway
that's good now we could take solace in
that it was all predicted
uh number three here's uh here's
something new for a change
another new thing turns out the media
thinks that trump is literally hitler
that's a new spin you don't hear this
very often
pretty interesting let's uh let's take a
listen your history
much better than i do but during the
rise
of of hitler uh you ha yeah by the way
we can draw the analogies
as far as we can we can talk about this
being 1933
we can do that
a lot of businesses by the german
corporations
saw hitler as a clown they backed him
uh because they thought he was going to
be a bulwark
against communism against the rise of
communism across europe
socialism we've seen a lot of businesses
a lot of ceos a lot of the world's
richest people a lot of america's
richest
people back donald trump uh and back him
because it was good for their bottom
line
so the only reason a couple couple
points i want to make the only reason
i'm playing that
um first of all
we should understand that 90 of
historical analogies
that are offered in the context of
political arguments these days are bs
90 granted i'm just pulling that number
out of thin air but i i think we could
agree it's probably around 90
if not more if not like 99
and the other problem with the
historical analogies it's kind of like
the left when they're making literary
references
every literary reference is to harry
potter because that's the only book
they've read
and so world war ii and
and in hitler this is the only
historical event
and historical person that they're sort
of vaguely familiar with
and so every comparison has to go back
to
hitler and world war ii that's that's
all they've got
but by this logic that uh that uh what
he's talking about there
um that well the corporations
back donald trump and just like the
corporations and the rich people backed
hitler
you see that that's false on pretty much
every level because number one the
corporations don't back donald trump
they hate him
but by this same logic then i guess
black lives matter
are nazis by the same logic i mean
they're the real nazis right
because they're backed by by all the
corporations all the corporations have
come out
and given their uh their oaths of
fealty to um to black lives matter
so i guess there you go there's the
comparison
pretty easy to do or we could all you
know pick up a book
and read about a historical period some
just any other historical period that's
my challenge to everybody
reading history is great but just read
about some other so so we can at least
start getting some more interesting
and maybe illuminating analogies okay
number four huge controversy here
reporting from the daily wire
president-elect camilla harris is waging
what is likely the first public battle
of her tenure
and it's against vogue magazine
according to new york times harris and
her team are at odds with the high
fashion magazine's
editorial team over the decision to
select a casual photo of the vice
president-elect
for their next magazine cover instead of
a more formal photo
that they feel cast harris in a better
more professional light
new york times reports quote february's
issue issue features miss
miss harrison a dark jacket by donald
deal skinny pants converse and her
trademark pearls
she stands against a leaf green backdrop
bisected by a spill of pink curtain
colors meant to invoke or evoke her
howard university sorority
she's also wearing a pair of converse
sneakers and appears to be caught off
guard by the camera
um social media critics who slammed the
photo called it disrespectful then
there's a whole bunch of leftists
complaining that the photo is
disrespectful
i think the real disrespect is to the
curtain like what are you what are you
doing standing on somebody's curtain in
the first place
granted the card's a little bit long
longer than it should be but there's no
reason to stand on it
what i don't understand is uh she
was is this photoshopped like did she
not really wear those shoes and they
they photoshopped the shoes onto her if
so then i understand complaining about
it but
from what at least as far as i know with
photo shoots normally
you know you you put on the clothes
yourself and then you go and you post
for the photograph
so if she didn't want that photo to be
taken then why did she pose like that
but there's going to be a lot of this
kind of thing so just get ready for this
uh in the years ahead there's going to
be a lot of you know people
accused of not showing the right level
of respect to camille harris the vice
president
nobody's ever cared about respecting a
vice president before
especially not the one we have in office
right now
but now it's going to be this is like
royalty how dare you
uh essentially the way the media treated
michelle obama that's the way it's going
to be now
with camille harris where it when you
speak her name it must be in hushed
tones
of solemn reverence when you speak your
name you must bow your head
for three seconds just to acknowledge
her her gloriousness
that's the way it was with michelle
obama and of course we were always told
that no no
we're not favoring michelle obama it's
just the first lady we should respect
the first lady
and then we get melania trump in there
and and uh they
you know they're they're they're
publishing
secret tapes recorded of her by her
friend
just to embarrass her so that's the
level of respect there
all right number five um there's an
interesting article in vice that
i'm not even sure if i can read given
that this is a family show i'm already
regretting somewhat my decision to
pull this up but it's not really a
family show don't let your kids watch
the show in fact don't do that that's a
on second thought don't especially not
this part so
a hacker took control of people's this
is from a vice i'm reading now from vice
it says a hacker took control of
people's internet connected
chastity cages and demanded a ransom to
be paid in bitcoin to unlock it
the hacker said quote your penis is mine
now
according to one of the victims
according to a screenshot of the
conversation obtained by a security
researcher that goes by the name
smelly and is the founder of vx
underground a website the cleps that
collects malware samples
okay in october of last year security
researchers found that the manufacturer
of an internet of things
chastity cage which is a sex toy that
users put around their
privates and is used in the bdsm
community
and can be unlocked remotely but this
had left an api exposed giving malicious
hackers a chance to take control of the
devices
that's exactly what happened according
to a security researcher who obtained
screenshots of conversations between the
hacker and several victims
a victim who has to be identified only
as robert said that he received a
message from a hacker demanding a
payment of .02 bitcoin around 750
today to unlock the device he he
realized his cage was definitely locked
and he could not gain access
to it
okay let me just stop the story there
and say what
why would you i
you know what never mind i'm sorry i
brought this up there's nothing i could
say about this i have i have so many
questions
i have so many questions right now about
about this and why this exists
and what you're doing with it why would
you have something like that at all in
the first place
and if you do have it why wouldn't there
be some sort of manual kill switch
in case someone does gain access but
so many questions that i i can't dwell
on here
and i certainly can't google them so now
they're just in my mind
i have to carry them with me i have to
carry this mystery with me for the rest
of my life
and you do too so you're welcome
you know the question comes up a lot now
uh what are we going to do
as conservatives in the years ahead uh
when it's sometimes going to feel like
everything's stacked against us and all
the most powerful voices in the culture
are against us and you know there's
there's certainly a lot of truth to that
well here's one thing we can do which is
sort of stick together and support
grassroots organizations that align with
our values as conservatives that's one
thing we
should certainly be doing uh regardless
of what else is happening in the country
and in the world
and here's one to uh to consider serve
hq survey hq is a six-year-old company
that helps churches and non-profits
train and equip their volunteers to
serve their communities
they offer two online tools one for
training and one for communication
that thousands of churches and
nonprofits have used first their
training tool lets you build
simple online courses for your
volunteers and staff with
video-based training follow-up quizzes
automated step-by-step onboarding
which is also included in the package
they have a library of over
800 pre-created training videos that you
can use right away
with zero preparation and second their
online communication tool helps big
helps helps big and smaller teams with
texting email chat all in one place
so it's just it a lot easier for you and
your team it includes
mobile apps for iphone iphone and
android and it's designed to replace all
the different communication tools
that you might use for chat internal
email newsletters text blasts all that
kind of stuff
it's a central hub for communication
with volunteers parents and even
students
because it has safety and accountability
baked into the design their website is
servehq.church and again this is
this is a organization that that is
working for us in the culture so we
should
support them serve hq is offering a new
year special for any organization that
signs up
during the month of january use code
walsh to get 10 off
for life during this month only so
during this month 10 off for life
churches and nonprofits can train
volunteers teach core principles
communicate with teams and individuals
and automate recurring or multi-step
tasks so go to servehq.church to learn
more and to start your
14-day free trial now use codewalls to
get 10
off for life and um
listen what we've been talking about
this week what we've been facing
uh for for years now it's just gotten a
lot worse and ramped up
has been this attack on conservatives by
big tech um and with the actions of big
tech in the last week
you know it's it's it's pretty clear
that
they're not gonna stop it's only gonna
get worse which which just
you know gives some more fuel for our
fire here at the daily wire and and it
lets us know that we need to continue
with our already ambitious plans
that we've got for the new year uh we're
talking about investigative news and
entertainment content lots of new stuff
but we can't stop there we have to take
action to build or buy tech to protect
ourselves from the attack that's coming
so that we can continue to deliver new
content to you and fight back
we're exploring all possibilities for
this new data centers payment gateways a
lot more
the thing is though you know this takes
money it's just the reality of the world
and so we need more support we need your
support uh that's what we need
there are 50 million of you that we
reach every single month that engage
with our content
in the first phase we need we need about
one million members to take on the fight
now to put this in context
washington post has 3 million
subscribers new york times has 7 million
you go up to netflix they've got like 70
million or more
if you think all these companies need a
challenger then
and i think we could agree they do then
we need your membership
if you think your freedoms are at stake
then yet again we gotta we gotta join
together
and part of that is joining the daily
wire you can become a member at
dailywire.com
subscribe and tell all your friends do
this to do
the same let's get to our daily
cancellation
[Music]
well if you watch this show you know
that i strive for cancellation equality
um i believe that all americans have the
right to be canceled regardless of race
nation or creed
as you know i don't even make exceptions
for my own wife and children
basically the daily cancellation is a
time to focus on everybody's
sins and foibles except for my own of
course
and this is not just a time for mocking
the left is what i'm trying to say
that's what the rest of the show is for
and the daily cancellation like 85
of the time this though is one of the 15
percent and that is why we are canceling
trump
trump campaign national press secretary
hogan gidley
now the first thing to know about hogan
gidley is that he has a name that sounds
like somebody made it up on the spot
when they were being questioned by the
cops like hey you what's your name
my name uh hogan
g gidley i mean ridley
no gidley hogan gidley yeah and hogan
gidley if that's his real name was on
fox news yesterday
and uh here's what he said listen with
the social media crackdown does he feel
emasculated
especially as he heads out of office
look i i wouldn't say emasculated i mean
if
the most masculine person i think to
ever hold the white house is the
president of the united states
but what he does see is a systematic
attack against not just him but against
75 million americans who disagree
with the socialist communist vision that
democrats have for this country
okay now granted the question was kind
of dumb is he emasculated by being
kicked off twitter
uh and the answer is probably no i i
wouldn't consider that an emasculating
move if anything it's emasculating to be
on twitter uh as
as as i am but
still uh the the answer to that question
cannot go uncanceled i just i cannot let
that go
president trump is the most masculine
person to ever be president hogan gidley
says
now partly this goes back to the
cancellation last week when we canceled
political personality cults it's a
phenomenon to be found on both sides of
the aisle and it's equally grotesque in
both
in trump's case there is no denying that
some of his supporters and advocates
take a slavish
obsequious approach to him showing a
degree of servile obsession that simply
has no place in america
least of all on the right support
politicians when they do stuff you like
criticize them when they do stuff you
don't like that's what our relationship
with them should be
in all cases no matter the politician
but the second problem here
is that it's historically inaccurate and
to my mind erases and otherizes teddy
roosevelt
who actually holds the title for the
most masculine president ever
without question and this is with all
due respect andrew jackson who killed a
guy in a duel
once beat an attempted assassin with his
cane guy came up and tried to kill him
he beat him with his cane george
washington also led us to victory in our
war for independence
uh grant one of our greatest civil war
generals
all very manly teddy roosevelt though
still stands out as the manliest i think
many pieces of evidence could be
presented here he was a cowboy a war
hero a sheriff a rock climber
a jungle explorer this is all one dude
by the way
he's also a police commissioner big game
hunter and oh yeah he was he was
president too
basically if you're a man think back to
childhood
and all the things you wanted to be when
you grew up
roosevelt became all of those things
while many of us became
none of them in fact true story a couple
days ago i took my kids out to eat and
we were sitting down at the restaurant
my my kids were quizzing me about my
childhood i think partly because
they don't quite believe that i had a
childhood and at one point my son asked
me what i wanted to be when i grew up
and and uh
i told him that when i was a kid you
know i wanted to be different things but
mainly either a cowboy an explorer or an
astronaut
and my son thought for a minute and then
he said wow daddy
you didn't become any of the things you
wanted to be
and all i could do was just nod
and then weep silently into my plate of
onion rings
anyway other fun facts roosevelt held
boxing matches as president
went skinny dipping in the potomac as
president helped to invent football as
president
but i could almost put all those aside
and give you just one detail about
roosevelt that i think seals the deal
you're probably familiar with the story
but here it is again um
before arriving for a campaign speech in
1912 roosevelt was
shot in the chest by an assassin on the
way to the speech
now fortunately for him he had his
speech folded up in his breast pocket
and also fortunate he was very
long-winded so
it was a long speech it was like 50
pages he had it all watered up and
the paper along with his eyeglass case
slowed the bullet enough to save his
life
but he went to give the speech anyway
with the bullet lodged in his chest
he began and he began his speech i think
with maybe the greatest opening line in
the history of public speaking he said
this was his opening line
friends i shall ask you to be as quiet
as possible i don't know whether you
fully understand that i have just been
shot
that is a great opening you know i do a
lot of public speaking and uh
and you know they always say with public
speaking it it's really important to
grab them
with with the opening line and nothing
can be better than
hey everybody i was just shot anyway
today i'm going to tell you about
xyz but then he showed his bloody shirt
and uh you know he said that the bullet
is in his chest so he might have to cut
the speech a little bit short
he still spoke for 84 minutes
and keep in mind there was no like
microphone so he was he spoke for 84
minutes
shouting to this crowded room with a
bullet lodge in his chest
can you imagine any modern politician
reacting that way
with modern politicians they would stub
their toe on the way to the podium
and demand to you know demand a medical
evacuation
because of it so roosevelt
was the manliest by far without context
a contest
and to top it all off he had an
exquisite mustache
indeed he was he was among the last of
our presidents to have facial hair
and look at what has happened to our
country ever since the babyface
presidents took over
what does that tell you and that is why
roosevelt
is not canceled but unfortunately
hogan gidley is canceled today
uh and that'll do it for us today on the
matt wells show thanks for
watching thanks for listening have a
great day godspeed
[Music]
the matt wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling
our technical director is austin stevens
production manager pavel vadosky
the show is edited by danny d'amico our
audio is mixed by mike coromina
hair makeup is done by nika geneva and
production assistant mckenna waters
the matt wall show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 21.
house democrats try to impeach president
trump andrew cuomo finally promises to
open up new york
and kamala races the cover of vogue
check it out on the michael knowles show